when your husband comes out of the
shower get on your knees and suck some
positivity into that man I want to speak
to a husband because there's a big
question mark on you
I've come together with the one on my
charity which is 100 donation policy and
do amazing work around the world this
winter brother sisters helped to feed
those who are in poor conditions and who
don't even have a clothing to keep
theirself warm your small donation might
mean nothing to you but it can change
their life and help them survive the
winter this year
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys so a couple of days ago I
done a video pertaining to the sister
about her saying that she doesn't mind
her friend of her friends marrying her
husband I found that a bit weird and odd
it's not in who in a woman's nature to
be totally okay with her husband
marrying someone let alone marry her
friend does this mean that men are not
polygamous by nature and they shouldn't
do it no that's a different story I'm
not saying that so I found that bizarre
I've done a video it was mediocre and I
said we assume the best and I gave her a
bit of Nasir however these two new
videos that came out or old ones
whatever they may be I found the need to
do another video because to clarify so
people don't think that I'm okay you
know just give her a bit of Miss here no
I'm outright going to be warning about
warning against this couple but I'm not
going to be talking to her I'm going to
be talking to her boss which she refers
to her husband
which I don't mind if you want to see
husband as a boss that's fine and not a
really big deal but I'm going to talk to
him because it seems that the problem is
with him not necessarily with her even
though she might be to believe as well
here's the two clips Let's Talk About
Sex
the first time I had sex was pretty
difficult you know um
husband was very mashallah well endowed
um the whole point of sharing this is so
that people know most of the time that's
one as I watched the video if you take
out contests just with that begin a bit
which I'm going to come to but the rest
of the video it's kind of balanced she's
talking about real situations but to
start that video like that it's very
very distasteful and to me it's very
weird and I'll tell you why now this
next video is the one that you know
um
yeah worship for yourself
when your husband comes out of the
shower get on your knees and suck some
positivity into that man then go sit him
down turn on the TV and give him
something to eat hop in the shower and
come back and give him some dessert too
many women complain to me and they're
like he never lasts long enough
now he will and try it and if you really
want to learn more go get my book I want
to speak to a husband because there's a
big question mark on you you don't show
your face on the camera she was she's
always behind there saying things I
don't know if it's coming from her I
don't know if it's coming from you but
to me there's a big question on your
hero your protective jealousy
and there is a big question mark on her
higher now what do I mean by this
it's very clear that she's dressed up
modestly but hijab is not just putting a
cover over your head or your body
it is what comes out of your mouth
that there seems that is greatly lacking
now your husband maybe doesn't have the
audacity or wants to show his face for
God knows whatever reason I find it very
bizarre why don't you show your face you
don't show your face but you are okay by
putting your wife or whatever for
whatever reason coming out here and
discussing things that are not real from
the polygamy issue of marrying her
friend look he might be an exception to
the rule may Allah increase you in more
core wives no problem I've got nothing
with that I've always said I am
propolygamous and I believe every man is
polygamous by nature and I vocally say
that so I'm not here to please the
sisters I'm being very honest and brutal
it is a solution but for you to come out
there and say oh my husband is very you
know blessed I'll be honest if I was
your father I would be very very
disturbed best believe I'll be coming to
have more than a word with you where is
your Haya where is your shame in public
talking about your husband and what he
does or how blessed he is or whatever
keep your blessings to yourself enjoy
your blessings in your privacy you don't
need to scream out to everybody number
one evil eye has had that's one issue
but the lack of modesty and for your
husband to allow you to do that when we
know the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him said Allah doesn't look at somebody
who or something along those lines
there's a there's like it's it's severe
the one who goes and shares his intimate
things with his partner this is wrong we
cannot go to people and be like oh you
know what did my wife yesterday yeah and
if people ain't talking about man over
your woman for your wife what you're
talking about is permissible but for you
to go and talk in that manner this is
not an action of a real man's sister I'm
just going to refer to you for a bit
then I'm going to speak to your husband
now you're coming and saying that you
get on your knees and suck some love
into him or out of him I don't know what
what the whatever you said yeah sister
where is your shame why what is your
shame well lie if I was your father I
would disown you man now comes in what
is that it's disgusting it is disgusting
not only that may Allah preserve your
marriage may Allah protect you from evil
eye or whatever it may be and may you
guys be together until death and then
Jannah but my dear sister what if one
day you divorce or this man decides to
divorce you do you think any man would
be watching that and be like let me
marry this woman no after the stuff you
said believe me yeah men have a
different kind of Gira no man's gonna be
like oh yes oh oh who's your wife or my
wife is that sister you know he came and
said uh that um she used to do this to
her ex-husband men sometimes can be
insecure to their ex-partners
ex-partners past Haram past this is in a
man's nature some men just feel unless
you hear about that for you to do that
to yourself in your future just in case
if things went pear-shaped may Allah
preserve you guys and protect your
family unit we don't want that to happen
to your husband my dear brother how are
you putting your wife in front of a
camera okay she has she dressed up
modestly doesn't seem like she has
makeup or whatever little I've seen the
issue here is this you are now for some
odd reason every time you make a video
you're talking about this book and this
website this book and this website I'll
be honest we should assume the best but
um
that we used to judge people based on
wahi when why he stopped we judge people
based on what we see we judge from the
apparent so personally I would say there
is something off and there's something a
bit weird I don't know what will come
out in the future but it seems like you
are very obsessed with this book you
want to sell and this website you want
people to go and sign up to and very
bizarrely you're charging 200 I thought
it was 27 pounds 27 an hour
271 for some reason otherwise 271 pounds
yeah one dollars per hour for marriage
counseling what are you doing giving
diamonds and gold on the side is it a
holiday package as well
271 pounds excuse me Dollar to me I
would say guys be very very wary that's
the reason why I'm blocking out the
website name and mutiko when she
mentions a book to me though something's
very questionable because she is giving
a false idea to men as if this is how it
is now don't get it twisted of course
you know you are allowed to have oral
intimacy with your partner it is
permissible there's nothing wrong with
it you can have that there's many things
that you can do yes many things you you
can do however to give this false
perception that certain things are okay
is not because you're given a false
reality to men as if that's how it's and
they're putting their wives in question
that's not the case so Brothers stop
watching individuals like this public
figures like her who are who are
irresponsible in their message and are
too busy by my book go to my website buy
my book go to my website it's literally
on there she doesn't even deny it she
says yes that's what I do if somebody
lacks higher and I'm so sorry if her
husband in this in this specific aspect
records his wife or allows his wife to
say such things there's issue yes
there's a real issue here all they're
doing is promoting book and website
obviously very be very wary and stay
away if they were responsible they would
come and discuss the issue of polygamy
in a mature way in a civilized way so
people can understand and benefit from
it but to me with the lack of higher and
the money side of it there's a big fat
question mark so so I would say be
careful and my dear sister I ask you to
remove these videos if you want it for
the sake of Allah you don't do anything
for me removing for the sake of Allah
have some higher please have some higher
and to your husband I don't know what
your guy's agenda is whatever it is
right now there's a question mark please
it's very hard to speak to another
sister brother in this way I'm so sorry
but I'm going to be real because there's
people people's money and people you're
going to be taking for a ride at stake
here please have some more hero over
your wife and tell her to stop doing
such things and speaking in such ways
you allowing this shows me I'll be
honest with you you can have three four
wives yeah if you're allowing this let
me tell you something if I
within that situation and my wife for
example was over the moon if I got two
three four wives and she spoke like that
I'll say you know what I'd rather be I'd
rather be with one wife than having my
wife speaking in that manner about
intimate things with no hair that's all
I had to say may Allah forgive me if I
say anything to hurt anybody but I found
the need to do this video because after
the polygamy video which was very
balanced and I said let's assume the
best in the sister when I saw these
videos I don't want people thinking okay
Ali just you know gave her anaseebo said
you know let's assume the best no
there's no assume the best now throw
assume the best outside in the bin
please be wary of these individuals not
just uh these public figures who make
their you know as if marriage is all
hunky-dory and holidays are the same
irresponsible people till next time